tapis rouge pour cameron krausmann
invité par l' orchestre de chambre i
musici de montréal
depuis son retour au pays après sa
sortie du conservatoire de musique de
paris
le violoncelliste prodige est très en
demande
je vois plein de possibilités de faire
de nouveaux projets de travailler avec
de nouvelles personnes
et voilà d'abord à d'avoir la chance
aussi d'avoir lac une carrière qui
marche qui commence à marcher
cameron 24,1 et ni à calgary en alberta
dans une famille de musiciens
mais il a passé son enfance en ontario
il a commencé à jouer du violoncelle à
l'âge de 7 ans on dit souvent que c'est
un instrument qui se rapproche à la
brian a rappelé être pas en tant que
timbre mais surtout en terme de a-2 de
son étendue des registres parce qu'il
est vraiment à il a tous les registres
de la voix humaine
[Musique]
après son secondaire le jeune homme
amoureux de la littérature française du
19e siècle a poursuivi ses études au
conservatoire de musique de paris où il
a remporté le prix de violoncelle avec
les félicitations du jury
depuis cameron se produit sur des scènes
prestigieuses en europe et en amérique
du nord
surtout dans des concerts de musique de
chambre dont il est spécialiste
il avoue une préférence pour debussy
mais il aime aussi travailler avec des
compositeurs contemporains canadiens
notamment l ces moments de partage avec
des compositeurs d'expérimentation de en
tant qu'interprète de voir comment
prendre l'idée d'un compositeur et le
faire ressortir sur son instrument et ça
c'est le violoncelle stradivarius
bonjour nous parlant d' instrument
pendant trois ans cameron a pu jouer
avec un stradivarius un violoncelle
baptisé bonjour vieux de 300 ans qui lui
a été prêtée par le conseil des arts du
canada
un privilège pour le jeune virtuose
souvent je me je me trouvais à jouer
d'un instrument et à me dire
en fait je vois écouter l'instrument
parce que l'instrument il connaît et
sait comment jouer la musique parce
qu'il a tué tous tous vécu et c'est moi
qui va être écoutés l'instrument il va
tout apprendre sur comment jouer et
c'était très spécial de pouvoir non
seulement tenir l'histoire mais de de
faire partie de l'histoire aussi sa
place dans l'histoire de la musique
cameron krausmann est en train de la
faire une carrière qui promet d'être
fructueuse
[Musique]